good but more important is they say we  need a black i have no problem  with a black james bond as long as it's  the girl who played precious right no oh  what but the issue here what it goes  super woke why do you mean a black james  bond this is the issue when people talk  about it's like you're injecting race  where it doesn't need to be let me just  say this one thing  this is one area when people talk about  it black james bond there is no lack of  representation of black american men in  the action hero genre if you were to  have will smith at his peak right will  smith men in black independence day and  run it opposite a james bond vehicle on  the same weekend will smith would have  decimated it will smith denzel  washington for crying out loud they  tried to sell us jamie foxx as an action  hero  [ __ ] shaq there are plenty of black male  action heroes